nous sommes entrés dans une quatrième
vague du virus nous devons tout mettre
en oeuvre dès maintenant pour que cette
vague ne soit pas aussi plus
dévastatrice une hausse de ce type je
les dis aussi forte aussi soudaine nous
n'en avions jamais connue depuis le
début de l'épidémie dans notre pays oui
c'est la demande des efforts et cela
demande une adaptation une organisation
nouvelle pour permettre l'application de
ce pass sanitaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons décidé que dans un
premier temps une période de rodage
s'appliquerait c'est à dire que les
personnels les forces qui vont être
mobilisés pour les contrôles vont l'être
dans un premier temps pour
l'accompagnement des établissements dans
la mise en oeuvre du pass sanitaires
concrètement l'article dans le projet de
loi prévoit bien l'extension du pass
sanitaires pour les centres commerciaux
dont la superficie excède un seuil qui
sera défini par décret et il prévoit de
manière écrite dans l'article que le
cadre le pass pourra être requis dans
les centres commerciaux
dès lors que sera garantit l'accès des
personnes aux biens et aux produits de
première nécessité notamment
alimentaires à l'échelle du territoire